Hey, everybody, my name is Bradley Knapp, and
we've come together today to talk
about what is a dedicated host?
Dedicated host is a construct that
you see a lot in the world of cloud,
but it's a little confusing. What does this
dedicated host thing actually mean? Why does it
look like it's so expensive when you compare it
to buying a dedicated instance or just a normal
virtual server? And the answer is dedicated
hosts are a way to provide single tenancy.
Single tenancy means that no one else can
run on the compute that you are running on.
So, if we think about a physical cloud host,
right, we've got our actual cloud server here.
This is the actual host that runs in the data
center. In a normal multitenant environment,
we would take, and we would divide that host up
into pieces, and every one of these pieces as a
virtual server that you would buy. I'll just mark
that as VSI. In a dedicated host, we still have
the same host, that same box that we were talking
about before. But instead, this is your box,
and you control all of the VSIs that schedule on
to it. So instead of this being customer A, and
this being customer B, and this being customer C,
this is all yours. And so you can choose to divide
it up however you want. You can have one third of
it go into one VSI and two thirds go into another.
You can divide it half and half, or you
can put lots of little bitty ones on it.
And so, the question, of course, always
becomes, why would I do this, what is the
value of a dedicated host? Why would I purchase
this thing? And the answer is really twofold.
First is that single tenancy that I mentioned
before. Single tenancy means that you don't
have to worry about anybody else being able
to crash through the hypervisor layer within
this host and get to your data. Even though it's
already incredibly secured in the world of cloud,
it's just one more layer of protection. This
is very important for health care workloads,
folks in banking and finance like that.
But in addition to that single tenancy,
it also allows you to schedule workloads
that want to be close to be each other, close to
each other. So, if we think of our example here,
where we've got two VSIs of the same size, let's
imagine a high-performance compute workload,
something that in the world of HPC, where you
have lots of compute working on the same problem.
In order to minimize latency and maximize
performance, you want to pack these onto a few
physical hosts as possible because data transit
through a physical host is much faster than data
that goes across the network. If we think about
our example over here, where we've got our multi
tenancy, and we've got multiple multitenant
boxes, every one of these has to link together,
and that link together takes time. There is a
latency penalty that you pay. But in a dedicated
host like we have over on this side, because these
all run on the same physical box, you don't incur
that latency penalty and you can order multiple
dedicated hosts in order to make that happen.
Thank you so much for your time
today. If you have any questions,
please drop us a line below. If you want
to see more videos like this in the future,
please do like and subscribe and
let us know. And don't forget,
you can grow your skills and earn a badge with
IBM Cloud Labs, which your free, browser-based
interactive Kubernetes labs that you can find more
information on by looking below. Thanks again.